[Music]
hello everyone and Dennis Bosch resident
grandmaster and this is viewers choice
sadly you've just missed American Dutch
secret training match which happened
just minutes before this lecture but
you'll learn about these games when they
play in real life I won't disclose the
names but you can't guess they're one of
them one of the players were number four
in the planet m2 and what Moe at one
moment so let's start with this game
that YouTube audience sent me between
Miculek and Colin hopefully I said it
right between two Romanian players
Miculek said that he had an amazing
position but then he bashed it up
somehow okay let's take a look d4 Knight
f6 c4 e6 c5 can somebody help me which
opening is this yes
the Benoni d5 well if white would want
it you could play Knight c3 and it would
transpose into some sorts of English
opening with one c4 so c5 d 5 takes all
very normal efore Bishop g7 Bishop e2
Castle castle a six a four ninety seven
ninety seven is a classical move here
but I think black should rather play
Bishop g4 trying to exchange this very
bad bishop if h3 just takes as most of
the time in these benoni structures the
Knights are better than the bishops but
black blade Knight d7 Bishop f4 98
in general white is slightly better in
these positions because of this D 5 and
E 4 Center and black doesn't really have
as much control over the center here
although he might be able to use this
ePHI square for the night later rook a3
bouquet 3 is a little bit early for some
reason for miss some mysterious reason
they still play rook a3 in these
positions most likely to bring the rook
to b3 but the main idea in this position
is something completely different
what else could by play for in this
position any ideas
Lex usual plan is to go rook b8 Knight
c7 and b5 will give you an example like
h3 rook b8
rookie you want you can't quite go to
Knight c7 immediate because the D pawn
is hanging and then b5 and if black
manages to play b5 blacks position is
usually pretty sound so white needs to
find a good plan himself so he won't be
left behind
if black plays b5
yeah an ID to Knight c4 is a good
suggestion which was actually played in
the game but there's a way of playing
this position either with a 5-2 stop
this b5 idea eternally and if black
plays b5 we just take Queen takes b6 and
rook a to actually I had a terrible
experience playing this with the black
side cuz after this very very quiet move
rook a - there's no more tactical ideas
for black you can't really double cuz
the on the B line because the b2 pawn is
just way to defend it for example if
rogue b8 I can just play let's say
Knight d2 against these Queen b3 threats
and 95 then how can we over protect our
position with white
it's basically a simple developing move
I'm looking for here Queen c2 exactly
Queen c2 and now everything is protected
the beet soup on will the beet soup on
will never be captured and if let's say
Bishop d7 because of this night on d2
even b3 as possible and night C force I
didn't consider taking on a6 because
Queen takes b2 and it can get messy
why doesn't need to do that you can just
play b3 and he's clearly better and
there is a good reason why this opening
is called Benoni which actually means
tears of god because black is just going
to suffer eternally is apart from
defending the a6 pawn he doesn't really
have a real plan and is mostly condemned
to defend the position forever all right
so f5 would have been an idea he played
rook a three queen e7 queen c2h6
92 now an idea - I think it's too early
it just gives too many space for black
how else could be playing this position
well this night is already the
suggestion is to move this c3 Knight
well the night is already very well
placed so you don't need to move it you
only need to move pieces that are either
undeveloped or they need to be removed
for some reason this Bishop f4 for
example can be threatened with this idea
of g5 so there is a typical move here
that my players play so in case of g5
they will have a stock move that they
can make yeah h3
so after g5 the bishop can drop back to
H 2 instead of G 3 because if the bishop
drops back to G 3 the main problem is
that black plays Knight e5 let's say
Knight d2 and f5 and the problem is in
this position black is threatening to
play f4 with a Tempe when if we put the
Bishop to h2 immediately that doesn't
work
95 92 f5 and now f4 doesn't really come
with a Tempe and in general f4 could
work and white is slightly better most
of the time I think white should be
better here so black played instead of
h3 white played 90 to 95 and this gives
some initiative for black for no reason
Knight c4 well Knight c4 is not a good
move for many reasons
my first question is who has the space
advantage in this position black no
black doesn't have the space white does
is exactly
white has the space advantage in this
position so why has no interest in of
exchanging of pieces so Knight c4
therefore is on killed 4 takes takes 5
in fact b6 would be an idea here to stop
a 5 and also a fruit b3 just simple rook
b8 and black should be fine in this
position but have 5 is plate rook e1 g5
ship d2 F 4 and in principle if black
manages to blockade the King side his
position is rather okay if not better
immediately a5 a good move trying to
find some play on the Queen side
night c79 a for now is principled as
he's actually heading to be six also
this night a for allows might to have a
great plan what is white planning in
this position where is white planning to
play in the forthcoming struggle on the
queenside so normally he would like to
open up the position there right
how can he achieve that before exactly
why does kind of planning this b4 idea
to blow up black stronghold on c5 and
then he will be much much better black
plays rugby eight which is kind of a
mistake he should have played Knight b5
that the idea of waltzing into the for
and if tonight manages to land on d4 big
trouble was coming so Knight b5 should
have been played but black played Bishop
d7 Ruby eight black they'd rugby eight
but he missed mites next move
it's light to move and get a big
advantage
what kind of tactical ideas can be
imagined in this position yeah the black
king is it-- is in the bullseye of this
Bishop e5 could be an idea that's one
idea what what other move can use the
fact that this bishop is eyeing the King
mm-hmm so now there's a question whether
we should play Knight takes e5 or II
so I have two suggestions you said II
five can you defend your opinion ye five
instead of Knight takes e4 so you're
saying that Knight takes e5 is good okay
can you tell me why Knight takes e5 and
not be five mm-hmm
because why mm-hmm if Knight takes e5
d-tix yes and discovered checked and
it's over so it's always important to
notice the pattern of the bishop
actually opening up or opening up the
diagonal for the bishop so we have to
decide if the move is either a five or
deny takes e5 if I've unfortunately
doesn't work as Bishop takes e5 there is
not enough tricks left in this position
so Knight takes e5 the good move and
Miculek actually played it King h8
Knight a for Bishop d7 and now the
situation basically completely changed
why does a pawn up and we need to decide
how we should continue in general we
should be much much better but we still
need to play actively to prove our
advantage how can we continue with
active play in this position
Bishop b4 is one way of putting pressure
on d6 how else can we put some pressure
on blacks position even though we're a
pawn up we can still play for the
initiative and we should
Bishop c3 is good move actually that's
what Michelet played but there's a very
natural move that could be played with
white and I would suggest that if I'd be
white
what's our versed piece in this position
the knight on a four is actually doing
nothing now so how can we improve that
can you raise your hand
yeah not b6 yes Knight b6 is a very good
move as it takes away the c8 square and
in the long run might be able to bring
the rook to c7 and that will be
devastating so if you build your
position and you play a five try to
bring your pieces and to b6 because it
will be good for you Bishop c3 Bishop e5
Bishop g7 Queen takes g7 b3 but I'd
still think that Knight b6 would be a
great move because now we can see that
already
you're very very close to infiltrate
through the C line takes b3 now I don't
like this move it's just too passive
even though we're a pawn up we still
need to play aggressive chess
otherwise we won't win the game rook e8
Queen B - now Knight b6 is obviously
still a move but how else could wipe
reorganize his pieces in this position
any suggestions
again what are White's worst pieces in
this position yes the night on a for
what else
mm-hmm not not the rook on e1 the other
Brooke the other work on it
III is doing absolutely nothing now
so how can we be organized that these
pieces come to life again yes well we
just played b3 so playing b4 now would
be a waste of tempo and not not a good
idea
general here
well we could want for one thing we can
reroute the Knight to c3 defending the
e4 pawn so we'll never drop that then
they're also exchanges are not bad for
us we're still upon up so we should be
much better here how else can we
reorganize yes we're ok one even though
these moves seem passive from afar it's
very important to connect the rooks and
in the long run we'll bring the rope to
c1 and after Knight b6 again we're going
to be able to bring a piece to the c7
square b3 rook e8 between b2 was played
rookie 5 black is consistent with his
play though he doesn't want to exchange
Queens and he's trying to put as much
pressure on white as possible ok 1 a
good move with the same intention we
were talking about f3 Knight b6 I'm not
fond of the timing of Knight b6 here
what is the issue with Knight b6 it in
this very moment
what should I be concerned after f3
yeah his King side pawn structure so how
can he save his King side pawn
structures so it doesn't get ruined
yes g3 yeah and then white would be
clearly better and I don't think that
white would have any problems after g3
so Knight b6 F takes G to obviously
black takes the moment when he can and
takes on G to Bishop b5 it takes b5
rogue d1 rugby one again I don't like
because rook c1 would make more sense
with the hope of sometimes invading on
the C Line rook d1 is actually not doing
much 98 Brooke c1 now this is a good
move even though white raised to the
Tempe but rook d1 sometimes realizing
your mistake and playing the good move
the second time it's still better than
not playing the good move at all
Knight f6 rook c8 I like this move rook
c8 why is this rook c8 moves so good yes
yeah so as you said you're correct
saying that if we manage to exchange off
pieces here some material up or we have
at least some hopes for a passport so
most likely we will be winning the
position so exchanging pieces in this
Benoni structure is pretty good for a
while right now
rook takes c8 Knight xc8 Queen d7 means
c3 a very strong move planning to invade
on the C line while defending the c8
night King gate 7 Knight b6 Queen f7
Queen f3 bringing the Queen closer so
the King will have some defenders around
it it around it
g4 it takes h5 f for now f4 is a bit too
aggressive because black usually tries
to mate white in the benoni defense and
if he doesn't manage to do so he'll lose
but by playing f4 white is playing into
the hands of black G takes f 3 Queen
takes f3 check rook g5 action Knight
takes e4 would seem like a decent move
rook g5 night c8 Knight takes e4 97-90
to Knight takes g6 now
before coming here I checked this
position and I think g6 wasn't too good
actually white is winning here
how can might win this position white is
attacking black screen on g6 but it's
his own queen is attacked on f3 so
naturally you might think of a way of
double attacking and possibly that's the
solution but how can we do it in this
position it's actually very complicated
position yes mm-hmm which one you'd feel
pain Ethiopian f4
mm-hmm okay so we have suggestions of
Queen III and Queen F for anyone wants
to have their own back what should be
the good move here so one of these moves
were winning the other is not winning
according to the engine shockingly in
this position Queen III doesn't win
Queen F for wins and also Queen F two
wins now I'll show the ones that win
Queen F 2 is the cleanest actually
because after Queen age 6 White has a
very simple solution of checking
and oh it's not in here
you know seven Jack
Queen
checks
is supposed to win somehow
so this is supposed to win but actually
Queen f4 is the cleanest I mean kena for
is the other solution
apart from Queen f2 and to create six
this made me laugh very heartily the
only move that wins in this position
queen f2 that makes absolutely no sense
but Queen after is the only move in this
position that wins
it's unbelievable it's mostly because
it's mostly because black cannot afford
to defend all of his pieces while black
will just run out of moves for some
reason I don't know why green f2 yeah so
nigh g6 was played
even though Queen f2 or Queen f4 his
winning 96 nine takes f3
I have faith Kenny G one rook F one King
takes rook takes f3 Guinea seven check
check and rookie three and instead of
checking Y decides to go rook c3 now
this is a very unreasonable decision I
think with white if he's actually trying
to make a draw there's no reason to get
out of the perpetual if he's trying to
win he should have tried winning when
the Queen's were all I think can get six
rooks e7 black made a nice defensive
move here
not Luigi rogue g7 correct
Brooksie to king e5 roopd - and now
black is suddenly much much better
because of his King being so active and
the White King shutout King e4 rook f2
takes rook f5 guinea for rook takes b5
and now the position is materially equal
but the D pawn is just much much
stronger than these bonds y-yes it's a
passed pawn that's one of the reasons
it's very strong and there's another
reason why this pawn will get extremely
strong in the endgame that is not quite
the reason that we can exchange pieces
actually it will have to do with the
difference between those two Kings
the White King get shut out so it cannot
support any past bonds
unlike the black King on e4 which will
help nurse this pawn into beautiful
Queen the 5 B 4 D 4 takes d3 ok JD to
Luke the 8th King g3 b5 rook g4 and
after building bridge and threatening
wookie for an rook d4 White is totally
busted because there's no way I can stop
this deep on from promoting so why took
on D - sadly takes h3 r okay for takes
King G tanking meter and this as you
point out is lost for white it's that
game from White's perspective as he
played the middle game very very well
but should have played much more
courageously in the later part and if he
would have tried to outsmart his
opponent in the tactical complications
most likely he would have at least
cleansed the draw or a win so coming to
the next game let's say see a bloods
game
knight c6 even Bishop d2 is a rare move
knight c6 is even rare in this nîmes Oh
structures a3 takes takes d5 C takes d5
I'm not fond of this C takes d5 idea
because it just loses time white should
be aiming to develop his pieces with III
castles Knight f3 and possibly Bishop d3
castles C takes d5 therefore is not that
good
Knight takes d5 efore takes takes
castles b5 - d5 move not so great here
yes yes it's aesthetically unpleasant
even to look at it because why just
gives up this beautiful Center which is
aesthetically very nice and after d5 we
can see it doesn't look good it just
doesn't feel right also white is
neglecting development 95d take c6
Bishop takes c6 takes takes rook d1 now
if you're black what should what you
should be doing in this position
yes if if you're black what you should
be doing in this position you have like
one two three four three Tempe up with
black yes
trade off yeah so it's a good idea to
exchange and actually black did play
Bishop b3 rook d8 and whites main issue
is that he's like to tempies behind he
would be maybe around equal if he could
develop his pieces out it's already kind
of too late
white is totally taking over and black
is totally taking over King bee to
Bishop c4 takes takes King b3 ID to
black is just collecting everything but
this g3 was very bad move obviously
allowing Knight takes f2 but it didn't
happen for some reason Knight f3 takes
rook F 194 tidy for c5 now I don't think
c5 is such a great move white has some
threats now how can we defend against
those yes
mm-hmm yeah but how can we in this
position how can we just develop our
initiative with black because white has
one little trick up his sleeve
in this position it's a simple one but
still there
what's undefended for black yes so why
does threatening to bring his rook to e1
and get have some background tricks so I
think g6 would be an idea just to create
a lift for the King now black plays c5
which shouldn't be played because it
just weakens the structure on the
queenside night b5 okay six again moving
away from the right squares the rook
belongs to the D line also root D to
check would have been much stronger okay
six rook e1 rook a five which is again a
blunder because if rook takes e4 if
takes then it's checkmate
so c4 Knight f6
Ruki seven eight six would be 794 okay
seven and the only reason I'm showing
this game this part of the game
is that black is neglecting something
crucial what isn't black not using in an
endgame yes his King the king was
stationing on g8 forever whenever you
see and you play an endgame bring your
King much closer to the center so you
can stop for example this a pawn from
queening a4 not G for a 593 g5 which is
again not a great move because King
takes would win but a6 is winning just
because of the fact that the king is so
far away King f8 takes
h5 knight c6 and the pawn promotes so
really the moral of this game is
bringing your king when it's an endgame
for example if he would have played the
normal g6 move let's say king d3 Knight
c5 here 96 takes takes rook d1 King F
eight and just because I brought my king
closer if white plays rook d7 I can play
a rookie seven and already all of my
pawns are defended I'm just completely
winning that's kind of a way of winning
and games by bringing your King into the
game okay let's see another game this
was a chest outcome game as far as I
know d4 d5 c4d takes what opening is
this can anyone help me that yeah the
Queens gambit accepted
efore b6 now this is a very bad move
black should be playing a five or Knight
f6 a la Korchnoi who wants to get an
all-you-can like position with E 5
Knight d5 takes Knight b6 knight c6 and
Bishop f5 or Bishop g4 it a lot but a
lot of theory it's an interesting game
the black plays b6 which is not good and
not the best among the alternatives
Bishop takes e4 Bishop b7 Knight c3 g6
a3 I like this a3 move kind of creating
a hideout for the bishop on a - Bishop
e7 Knight f3
I'd have 6 in c2h6 now this h6 move is a
little bit suspicious because White will
attempt to play along this be 187
diagonal castles castles Bishop rook e1
a6 Bishop f4 c5 rook t1 b 5d takes c5
queen c8 bishop a to Queen takes e5 and
how can white continue in this position
how can might put pressure on this
diagonal
yes yeah this should be one and now this
is deadly it's like poison for black
because the only way to stop in these
type of positions this battery from
mating is to play g6
but sadly g6 is not a good move here
because Bishop takes h6 that is the
reason why black should have thought
about that and refrain from the idea of
h6 and should have tried to use the pawn
as a shield instead of just playing it
there - 8 6 e 5 well that's a sad
concession but there's not much that
black can do here Bishop takes e5 97 it
should be 4 in c4 c5 and now black is
just completely lost because the knight
cannot move because it's checkmate g6e
takes f6
takes takes bishop a2 and again the
bishop on a2 is the hero of the day and
after Queen takes g6 black is just
completely destroyed checks and green
tea green h7 checkmate
and last but not least the game of the
day and I would call it the Greek gift
or the gam from Greece
Jonathan Shands found this game and
suggested this one for me and he called
it the eternal YouTube the eternal
YouTube submission and I would agree
so Liotta's the person who sent us this
game let us see this position said that
he felt that this combination was pretty
good and in hand side I have to agree
efore d5e takes d5 and everyone would
play queen takes d5 here but he plays
ethics can anyone tell me what's the
name of this line it's a very rare line
and never heard of it before
it's the bouquet gambit in the
Scandinavian defense so unsurprisingly
why it has to take and he does Bishop
takes c6 Knight f3 Bishop c5 a very good
aggressive move even though what really
should have played a very natural move
here how should white continue in this
position yes the d4 of course and after
Bishop b6 c3 just building a wall so
this Bishop will never ever have any
chance of having any technical ideas on
the white King but white played Bishop e
to develop peacefully Queen e7 Castle
Knight f6 Knight c3 a6 now instead of a
six naruto's should have followed it up
with some speedy development how can
black develop more speedily than a6
castling is quite speedy but black is a
pawn down so naturally he should make
the position as sharp as possible if
your opponent castles short what is the
way the sharpest way to play the
position yes yeah
Castle opposite side so how can we do
that yeah but knight c6 exactly knight
c6 and if d4 castles we're going for
mate now even after Bishop e3 we might
use our method of devil-may-care and
just play Knight g4 and just jump at his
throat trying to destabilize this Bishop
on the e3 instead black played a6 which
is a little bit slow though
d4 this should be six Bishop g5 knight
c6
and in the same way in how can black
react to d5 in this position there's a
very yell on castling this is actually a
very classic idea from the Scandinavian
and you might see them in many of those
games but why decided to play Knight e4
castles and he should have strengthened
the center with c3 and then black would
have been in trouble to be honest
c3 would have been pretty good but he
took on f6 G takes f6 Bishop e3 and the
computers agree right now and I would
also say to say so black has very good
attacking chances now it will g8
naturally looking and eyeing this g2
pawn g3 the bishop h3 rook e1 Bishop g4
what's the main idea of Bishop g4
yes
yeah it tries to take advantage of the
night being very weak but what else does
Bishop g4 indirectly attacks it directly
attacks the night
what else is threatened at the moment
yes no the d4 pawn the idea of Bishop g4
is one thing to attack the knight on f3
but also to destabilize the d4 pawn and
that's the main idea of that move c4
which again misses the point and should
have played c3 c4 he's trying to lock
the bishop though at five Queen c2h5 now
white is getting tricky he wants black
to take what temptation doesn't work
here because Knight takes takes bishop
takes d4 and if black would take the
bishop
why I could go haha and take the g4
bishop and black can take it back
because the Queen is hanging so h5 with
the intention of opening up the position
with h4 c5 Bishop a-79 h4 and the Greek
game commences it's black to move and
play a spectacular sacrifice
yes mm-hmm and after gtex h4
Bishop age 3 then I block you with
Bishop g5 even if you bring the bishop
to h3 or f3 I will still block you on g5
but you're close you're very close
yes you take the bishop just as a
reminder white wouldn't lose after
Bishop takes e - because of this nice
intermediate move of Knight takes f5 and
after the Queen moves just rookie - and
white as much better
so this Queen takes h4 sacrifice is more
than justified and also very good G
takes h4 Bishop takes e - now Bishop g5
is only move because King aged one
Bishop f3 is made so Bishop g5 only move
how should we continue here
while we were queen down so we might
need some more reinforcements to
actually break through
also we need a defender for this bishop
on it yes
rook de8 would run to rook takes E - yes
Knight takes d4 bringing in the night
and also defending the e - Bishop Queen
a for Knight f3 check King gage won and
now black comes up with brilliant
brilliant idea
he notices that this King on h1 is kind
of hapless and with a very clever
maneuver he will set up decisive threats
the soul of this combination lies on
this bishop the bishop is the hero of
this game so we need to save that soul
there would this bishop this should be
five exactly
and now after Queen F for Bishop c6 and
now the bishop becomes the monster of
this game and black is totally winning
Queen takes f5 immediately loses but
already
kingi to would run into rugby for ideas
and with millions of threats from black
right it's just completely lost for
example let's say Queen III Rho G for
check King f1 there should be five check
well it's kind of matter of taste if
Queenie 292 checkmate
but if we like taking pawns we can take
on h2 or rogue g1 exactly and that's a
spectacular finish sadly he played Queen
takes F he took first and men into this
night h4 double check and it wins the
Queen and the game but this game
deserves the finish of King G to rock g1
mate and this is the gang from Greece
[Music]
you
[Music]